men are in crisis being too pushy crying
at parks alfonso riviera spending time
at Arby's when they're not eating it's a
mess thankfully I'm here to help now why
am I qualified because I've got a
gender-neutral haircut a popular podcast
and time-to-kill I'm still in Community
College this is man up
[Applause]
this week I got a call from Lauren in
Culver City or Lauren as she says it and
she said that her man are having some
commitment issues something I know a lot
about I think I do I don't know if I do
I can't even like I can't even commit to
this nice to see you today how are you
I'm good
very lovely I thank you guys for meeting
me out here obviously we arranged to
meet you guys out here by this ledge
Laurens reached out to me via my podcast
which is about helping men take that off
the universe and really get that you
know that male gestation going on inside
of our lungs and heart so I called Theo
because you bought an engagement ring
this is true I did a year ago and you've
been sitting on it yeah mother handing
that thing they call that mother Henin
do they okay
and I feel like you thought that you can
just buy it and mother hunt it instead
of taking that next step to actually
propose like you act like you proposed
already but you haven't I wouldn't say I
act like I proposed because I mean I'm
not strutting around you know I'm
talking like I'm I'm perfect like it's a
huge step though well it would actually
be proposing it was an interim step you
know okay
it shouldn't take a year you're probably
right about that as men we have a lot of
like invisible hurdles some that you
can't even see as women just you know
cuz we have our own like behind errs han
you know we're the only animal in the
kingdom that runs forward at top speed
with blinders on you can't name another
animal that can do that unless it's a
blind animal buying a wedding ring and
not giving it to a girl is it's well now
you're just a dude that owns a ring a
jewelry boy
[Music]
so this is streets of rogue yes streets
of rogue this is my baby
you made this yeah yeah over the course
of four plus years Wow how many levels
are on this game 15 I'd say and so if if
asking Lauren to marry you is like level
fifteen what level do you feel like
you're on honestly probably fourteen and
three quarters ish I mean it's pretty
close or but it's but it here's the
thing it's been on fourteen and three
quarters for like a year or two so Wow
how much sex were you getting before
that you guys settled down do you feel
like you got enough sex out there in the
world I mean like I wasn't the best at
dating I don't think wasn't the worst
but you know I'm no player you know yeah
yeah I was good at dating but I wasn't
good at sex that's for my know I am the
worst at sex I'm very bad yeah what's
that what do you think the problem is
there uh I'll just get nervous I'm like
one of those faint you're those animals
that they faint mean they get nervous
you know know what animals are these
yeah they're like goats on the internet
and they faint when they get nervous and
that's how I am like I hold my breath
won't happen sex and then I'll just kind
of faint and it's a problem yeah I'm not
that good at it mm-hmm it sounds like he
thinks his ding hasn't had enough Ling
you know he hadn't done enough
tippy-tappy in that trippy trappy
[Music]
you've been sitting on the ring for two
and a half years right yeah if you're
afraid to make that jump one of the
reasons could be because you're worried
about not being able to be single again
so I thought I'd give you the
environment of what it's like to be
single
yeah and it's not really an environment
that I'm like familiar with that's okay
no I don't think anybody's comfortable
in it you know I think sometimes that's
it so this I do end it there's a guy
that it's comfortable in this shark is
comfortable in these waters you know
it's not that hard hey how's it going oh
hi sorry I didn't wave my hand at you
I'm matter harassed anniversa
Courtney nice man yeah Theo nice to see
ya there's my friend Matt hi Matt how
are you how's it going good I have
actually adult asthma oh no do you have
it I don't know I thought maybe we might
have some of the same issues and
diseases
oh no no have a good night okay you see
me struggling to breathe you know what's
up so I think it went okay yeah it went
all right it's a little weird yeah
here's the thing
she hated me before she got here she'll
hate me later but I converse ated I won
right so at least if I go home tonight
and ask to be by myself least I saw her
voice in my ears yeah you feel me yeah I
mean you're still a winner in that sense
yes yeah yes you got to take a win where
you can get a win right yeah so being
single is just about getting a little
wins so to have that single vibe you can
go out in here I want you to meet a
couple of girls all right we're gonna go
together or I'm gonna stay here and hold
on the nest you know god I'm a a jar of
just just I I don't even know I'm gone
freaking the out right now are you
really dad you know I know you're big
same and I'm big same in there we were
seen and look how far we've come
semen you got this all right
[Music]
hi I'm Matt hey good to meet you free
John yes hey good to meet you Matt hey
yeah how's it going tonight good how are
you not bad I can't complain too much
you guys having a girls night here
actually I could maybe do that like
what's the plans here the boo okay it
sounds like fun you guys gonna do like
like lines of cocaine there and all
kinds of crazy crap I'm sorry that's a
little forward I don't I don't mean to
like I'm sorry we were just like talking
oh I'm sorry I don't I don't I interrupt
you they'd said well what kind of girls
night are we talking here I have no idea
what I mean I'm sorry awesome
okay hey how's it going good I met Emily
nice sweet yeah I'm gonna meet you what
do you do I'm a video game developer oh
cool sounds fun yeah I'm very smart
some people have maybe said that in the
past I guess some all right
so you do a well for yourself do you
make good money yeah I do all right
a game my game is doing all right yeah
you obviously have like a cool job it
seems like you do well um I'm like
really really strapped for cash right
now and I could like hardly afford this
drink to be honest it's really
embarrassing but like is there any way
you could swap me like I was knowledge I
mean I I gotta say like I literally just
met you that's nice feel like a big
request I mean I know this is Los
Angeles filled with Lake
I do alright but I'm like I'm not like I
don't have you money you know I'm
like no no um yeah listen I'm really
sorry I can't can't really can't really
do that my friend but I'm sorry about
that okay all right Matt got thrown to
the Lions female LA Lions the Khan Eddie
cocaine instead of meat and they they're
naughty let it go I'm gonna have to go
with bad really oh yeah
you don't look I'm glad you got a taste
of the single life man you know but it's
an sometime it's a naughty taste yeah
okay it's like licking yourself when you
shouldn't and the kicker is why you've
been here being single with me the whole
time of course Lauren has been out being
single as well well I'm not trying to
trick you or anything but I just want
you to know that that's how it would
work I set up with my boy tasty Jimmy
he's chill as how tasty Jimmy yeah I
don't know we got the nickname so a lot
of chase gave it to him but that's his
life they didn't know this was the deal
Rob how would you feel if your girl with
some guy right now not so great
that's so great at all okay well I say
we go and check out what's going on with
them how about that you get this
you look really nice thank you okay yeah
go ahead it's not oh I was going to say
this is vintage like this better than it
actually reminds me of my favorite emoji
there's a senorita one oh yes yes I'm
knocking senorita which is a compliment
in the biggest way well look man I mean
that's what single lights like you know
yeah real real disappointing right and
so I wanted to show you if that's what
single life is like there and of course
if you were single then Lauren would be
single as well what kind of position do
you like you know I like I know we're in
a cab place but what about doggystyle I
mean is it it's tasty Jimmy yeah that's
him he's Italian something like a great
time in there right now I didn't want to
have to show you this but it's like you
know sometimes we don't we can't see
what we can't see
yeah the only until you see what could
be if you don't make a move on a special
girl
then then you don't know and this is
what that would look like man this dude
I don't know and a bunch of cats and
that's Jimmy dude yeah and he's
definitely I mean I heard he has him a
little bit of IDI erectile dysfunction
but he makes up for with his hands his
great-grandfather was a pianist Oh God
so I'm saying sometimes look man I know
you design games something you got to
design that final level and I'm gonna be
level with you last night I broke into
your house and surlis I don't recognize
those at all actually
oh well these are somebody's all right
but they also got this man is this yours
dad actually is mine that's um that is
the ring that I was gonna give to Lauren
yeah I'm gonna give win you know my
[Music]
yeah how does it make you feel whenever
you see that you know I don't know I
don't I don't feel good at all no time
like the present guy bring another foot
seem to the relationship already guy
will you can't design this but you got
to live it dude no time like the present
guy your usual yeah more tasty Jimmy's
you got this
hey tasty take a hike
is this pussy's mine not really how I
pictured doing this here but Lauren I'm
sorry I took so long to do this and you
know this is yeah pretty pretty pretty
weird way to do it but you know you've
been waiting a long time and I I do love
you and Lauren I yeah yeah hold on a sec
Lorne yeah will you marry me no yeah
it's the real thing and this week was
really really special you know they're
committing to a lifetime of love and and
matrimony and you know Sharon male but
Matt's not the only one who walked out
of that cafe with a new piece of plastic
I met this person sugar
you